[Music]
hey guys welcome back to all the records
where we talk about whatever we want off
the record he's determined to make an
intro for author but just it's never the
same one I know you're never gonna stick
with it's gonna be new every time
because it's off the record or because
you can't remember it how you expect me
to remember [ __ ] like that I think I
tried almost every street like a brand
new instrument all this you stopped
playing instrument huh you stop buying
instruments I got a lot I've been
learning something only buy things that
you have time for who taught you that I
just taught me that because because we
live in a smaller place now and I don't
have a five bedroom home with the
three-car garage so she was like you
have all this stuff in your closet and I
was like it makes you look like a
hoarder I am a hoarder
I am I recognize that now I don't like
to throw [ __ ] away
really I do not I hate it you're ordered
to yeah I yeah I think it's a memory
thing right like attach it to memories
like you can mental value to everything
baby clothes in particular like do you
save your son's things just whatever I
think is really cute and I'm saving it
for the next one I'll see that he's
still a baby so we just hold onto maybe
if he's five and then we still have it
then I think we'd horrible horny but
what do you like I still a baby I wish
my mom was a little bit of a hoarder she
has no sentimental value to you with
your brother stuff yeah my brother stuff
this woman has literally thrown away
childhood stuff in my face are you ever
gonna use this I was like yeah but
that's like my tech one okay she just
throws it away I'm like cool mom that's
great I'm also cheap was that what I
hoard cuz I'm cheap cuz I feel like I
need I'm gonna need this [ __ ] sweater
one cuz you say that right but then you
say you have like seven of the same
thing because you put it somewhere you
can't find it anymore so how are you
cheap you need to be an organized
hoarder yes you gotta do gel
chargers why why because I keep
forgetting where I put it so I buy
another one
that's true I have like 4,000 nail
clippers yeah I'm not I can't throw it
away though my version of that is
chapstick ketchup I buy like chopped
because I always lose it and I just put
one everywhere there's one of my
backpack one of my four you know I'm
tired of you [ __ ] your [ __ ] yellow
busy beeswax whatever [ __ ] pink
lipstick on what is it called
because yours has a little bit of
lipstick from yeah I don't have [ __ ] for
his mouth but he never has anything
anywhere so then I opted for like a 20
pack and I have it everywhere for him I
bought that busy bee's ones yeah I
didn't have the products all over the
place - I have a [ __ ] ton I always buy
new lipsticks and I feel adventurous
like all I'm gonna try this new color
know if I just end up sticking this even
critics color you have I know I have a
black lipstick oh [ __ ] and then I have
like a white one what ya are so
distracted yeah you're not you're not a
black or white kind of person I know
then I have them what you gonna do with
the white lips that you look like you
got highlight on your lips you should
figure a crack in yeah yeah what are you
doing a powder going out in [ __ ] it just
look like you'd really dehydrated a
bottle of water straight of white wait I
have like a really nude one that looks
white holes it gives your face no color
you know yeah mmm
can you do the Chola style line one day
please I could do it right now if you
want us to do it well be a do it and
then I'll take out your eyebrows he'll
[ __ ] and then do a McDonald's you
might think what you guys alright and
that if you do it after me yeah I used
to when I was in high school and I have
my trophies I would always do like the
brown lip liner everyone in the hello
sick crazy ass wing eyeliner when I was
15 though I was like
girl you look hot I got baby oil in our
hair is that how you made the creamy
baby oil on the hair is that how you do
isn't it crazy how like a simple product
can make you that unattractive yeah but
when I was 14 or 15 I thought that was
so hot though yeah that was like well
I'll be trying anyway any girls who wear
the [ __ ] adidas superstar with the
fat-ass laces that are baby blue either
that are cases yeah our case with I hate
a bit - Nike Cortez is all of those yeah
it's so interesting cuz all I want to do
is give you guys a napkin to wipe your
dirty [ __ ] mouths but that's what it
looks like it doesn't look like it
doesn't look like fashion it just looks
like gonna have a dirty you just look
like you [ __ ] just reminds me of when I
was 14 and 15 and we're going to the car
show who's going to the car show so
attracted to this yeah yeah I like girls
that look like clowns I end up married
blending mine though it's hard to keep
that I don't know he's in that the style
though you're supposed to look like a
clown Cupid's bow oh I think I just need
you to gel your hair all the way back
and then you'll be pretty much good big
ass bang you need the Peggy Bundy hair
with a baby it almost looks like we have
like a really thin mustache on top
that's what it looks like yeah you guys
have good though with the [ __ ] middle
dr. olla oh yeah you're good was my jamm
back in 98 dad you got those too
I just need to do that things you guys
twist your hair and put like those
little clips in I used to do with that
clear double butterfly Ville Clips back
in the back came a day when I was young
I'm not a kid anymore but sometimes I
wish I was a little kid again that's not
the other part but so you're going to
Palm Springs tell us about that why yeah
why'd you say like that like that I
think it's the brown now that stuck out
cuz I'm like very interested because I'm
jealous that I'm not going to Palm
Springs are you going to a prosperous
Hawaii like no automatically like I
wanted to [ __ ] go like this like
[Music]
crazy Chicano accent both of you that
same time they come down and you guys
make fun of me and deal let me - pretty
much - pretty much but do you even have
to act now
i'ma go to jail you better come visit me
going back home where's that jail yeah
I'm going to Palm Springs why because um
me and Jes just needs some time to chill
and have fun but the cool thing is so
like we used to do like road trips and
stuff and then one of the things that we
started really like liking to do is some
Oh people [ __ ] so like I never really
stayed at spa resorts before so there's
a ton it's pretty whole around like New
Mexico Arizona yeah but I didn't know
anything about these things like you
just [ __ ] play tennis golf there
there's spas there's just places to get
massages there's like it's just a
relaxation like extravaganza and we
found a spa in Palm Springs and then we
got a private it's like an outdoor
jacuzzi like a hot spring all right
literally an outdoor jacuzzi no it's
like every so it's not like a hotel it's
like little homes ah it's like small
little but without a kitchen and stuff
like that it's just a regular standalone
place and you get your own fence and
then you have your own little yard and
then there's like a Jacuzzi in there and
stuff and it's dough that's
mm-hmm and we could bring our dogs so
it's gonna be like a cat sounds dog
yeah what you see all right what did you
what did you hear no just stop that no
but you guys know like in our lives it's
hard to separate the personal and the
beast' nice because we all work with you
know our lovers and it's very different
from you know having two separate lives
and jobs and then coming back home and
then on the weekends you go it's like
there's a separation of it right but
then the stuff that we do I think it's
really difficult to kind of have couple
time and then work time yeah do you guys
work together a lot yeah and we would a
headphone we had like that headphone if
the headphones are in we just stuck to
the policy and that work don't talk to
me I'm on my headphones but yeah you do
like he'd be sitting with down working
and I'm like do you want to snack do you
want to drink you want lunch and I
always wanted to like you know nurture
him and he's like you know but that's
because he's here ya know he loved it
but like you guys don't have a Cold War
word you offered him sandwiches all the
time damn it Mary oh come on now cuz I'd
be like Oh wouldn't that feel like
I tell jazz if I'm if I'm on a thought
I'll come home and I'll be like
imagination time or like story time you
put your hand up but I just let her know
story time and I go straight into my
room too and it's like I don't I want to
recognize you but then also like I mean
I'm in a thought I can't be broken
through because she might be like oh
he's here she's like what are you doing
the other or whatever and my mind goes
there and it's not on the more important
things that I'm thinking about like you
know what kind of food am I gonna eat
later or what kind of karate moves am I
gonna do me like yeah
you guys go on date night we I have
specifically say okay when we go out
tonight we're not talking about work
we're gonna talk about anything else
other than work oh that's that's good
yeah we made it more intentional when we
had Tyga just because we just never did
that before him and then we just got
really scared like now we have this
other you know distraction from the
marriage not that there's anything wrong
with Tycho but we're like [ __ ] we've
really got to focus on each other now so
we've done that we've already gone out
like on a lover's retreat what like last
month like reconnect yeah yeah it's cool
to know we right before we go to sleep
we have like 10 minutes of like whisper
talk that's one type of sleeping all
right whispering and talking connecting
and then we would hear like taiko yeah
you know where you're like do here is he
do you guys ever think about having
working I'm done you're done kids yeah
how many kids drive one I want to get
there I know I want you to be 21
November and you guys believe it's a 21
year old one that's pretty amazing you
have a 21 year old what daughter
what a pair of shoes yeah a Doberman did
you have a kid when you were six seven I
was 16 yeah 16 my parents kicked me out
it was agree on story I mean we all
talked about one day um but yeah it's
like when you had a baby
Isaac why I was already moved out by the
time I got pregnant oh yeah I was 17
close yeah but I'm not her age you I see
you 20 years old the deep bass voice
exactly oh my god in a mustache Oh
driving thirty ten and I feel like he's
like oh my god stop growing up is too
bad imagine being twenty imagine your
son being 20 and then being like let's
do another no I mean some people do but
less
- like Isaac's dirty ten and I'm like
he's he's getting my dad he's like
already being really independent he's
almost a teenager go back to a date and
then take away and start all over again
I'm like I'm not here at [ __ ] up I
doesn't the digital husband when I had
Medicare he's like he what we have two
dogs and we love traveling so we're like
let's just do that I don't give a [ __ ]
but do you want have [ __ ] up I am yes
since now we've gone through the whole
kid thing I can't wait till you guys go
through it get you again but you guys
I'm in the sleep sucks ass but it's a
really cool experience but that's the
only part I'm like all man they're gonna
guess what [ __ ] I don't sleep anyways
oh we're gonna see you think you got it
but I sleep on an average of two hours
all right well then yeah no I don't you
baby got it
nope he's [ __ ] brain dead all the
time that's my mom she already has a
baby schedule planning my life for II
know I'm gonna be a millionaire so it
don't matter
cuz I'm not gonna work I'll be able to
give my all to the baby it's still tight
as a [ __ ]
waking up every two hours do you with
your husband as well you guys have like
that night time where you guys talk to
each other man and yeah I have to we
have to implement that right because
it's like he goes off on his day cuz now
he works and I work from home so there's
when you're married when you're dating
anybody in you're living together like
your day creates so much space like how
do you come back to where you're we
connected because otherwise you know you
just you become [ __ ] roommates and
then yeah I think Muriel would like that
too but I'm too [ __ ] goofy so she
wants that moment where we're about we
talk to each other but instead what I do
I take my cold ass feet that put on her
face no but because she'll cuz you'll
[ __ ] around to open it up he just
started drinking so I'm fine cuz I he
hasn't drank
that is only I think that's only a Vegas
thing do you daddy to drink or not
no I'm just saying like now we can
incorporate some alcohol to just kind of
like too low not too much wrong drug
addict though with Wyatt no cuz I gotta
like take a [ __ ] zantac for someone
oh okay okay finally I should have 30
minutes and then like if I could drink
like a normal person that I'm like okay
cool here's some wine drink okay cool
but it's just the preparation for it is
I got to time it out drinking is so
different when you're older too because
I feel like when I was younger I thought
I had a really good tolerance is that
that I might oz was great I seen your
foot yeah and you bounce backwards right
I can take [ __ ] like 11 shots of
course I can however the aftermath I
didn't care about but I care about the
aftermath now that it's 3d isn't it
though like the older you get the less
you can hold your alcohol even like
while you're drinking you get drunker
faster is that what it is I have no idea
but I'll just [ __ ] smashed like I
just said hi oh my god jade is what the
hell's going on yes it was like
ridiculously we should drink a lot that
we use like sounds like it's just
nothing did I feel like it's such a
common way for people to bond and
connect Oh like drink and it's like I I
don't get that part because I don't
drink
sorry guys I smoked crack you guys do
the ten minutes before Ben oh yeah yeah
we start doing that now so like at the
end of the day we just you know we chill
we talk we have a different I guess we
kind of like don't do the same routine
but it'll be like oh let's like talk
about the day just talk on the couch or
talk in bed or let's watch a show
together and just cuddle and were like
we do different things some point yeah
cuz I didn't know how important that was
it was like well we're in each other's
presence when you look together it's
only you have to try harder right can
you see them all the time so you just
feel like ah there's no more courtship
but you have to court each other
constantly yeah and the moment isn't as
cherished where it's like where when you
guys are apart I can't wait to see her
so there's like this like oh I wanna I
want to maximize that hour or two hours
we got together but then once they're
there all the time you're like oh I'm
just here tomorrow on the day after that
now it's not important anymore but some
important make it important it's
important to make an important report
every night we go out we have a balcony
and then we have like little what do
they call like my fairy lights and stuff
that out and yeah every now we go out
there and just hang out and we talk
let's go thank you guys it's so peaceful
i'ma tell Muriel just to be yeah man I'm
tell but this is like the Merrill
tonight here the [ __ ] up and then
we're learning the normal it's like then
this normal [ __ ] is like god that's what
you guys because our parents are
[ __ ] well kill our parents weren't
successful they're all [ __ ] marriages
that's why it's true I mean I grew up
with seeing my mom and my stepdad like
they were like roommates they never once
told each other that they were they
loved each other they met they don't
even call each other by like any
nicknames or nothing I was just like I'm
the first names very like cold it was
super cold I'll clean the [ __ ] room
all right when I came back from college
and then I saw I came back in right and
I scarred for life I saw my parents and
they were like kissing anything before
though they were they were flirting and
the first thing I thought in my head was
like wow that's adorable
the first thing I thought I was like so
hard oh god it was so you know I thought
you were gonna say I thought you gonna
see he caught your deaf finger in your
mom it was more they were flirting and
it was they were like in the backyard
and my dad was like like chasing my mom
it's I never witnessed ever like growing
up with my mom I wasn't with my dad they
used to have this thing where she he
would slap her ass all the time and I
remember being little like when they
were still together and I would go up to
my mom and I would like
your mom my mom no no me did you guys
ever try to jump back in her mom's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I think he's making himself look bad
[ __ ] lunatic all right anyway would
you should be like you brush you again
just brushing her teeth like this and
I'll just be army crawling on the carpet
even know that you came out of there at
that age alone - but you can is your
mom's fault
she was African I think like you know I
think actually aiming for Abajo because
I didn't know what a vagina was yes we
all know you didn't know that there was
two holes there all right there was an
additional Geordi on this show Oh we
separate he thought that women peed from
the vagina no you're kidding
that's the litter what I thought he
majored in biology he didn't vice my mom
told me that babies come out of the
[ __ ]
that's what my mom said - and I was like
I came back from elementary school like
mom you embarrassed me so much everyone
laughed at me because there's something
called the vagina and she got off yeah
then you went back and you got
embarrassed again because you called her
vagina no I think like he knew that I
had him in my belly because I was show
him photos of when I was pregnant so
what he would do is he would just lift
my shirt and tie like get in do your
belly better ya know like just to go
under my shirt you'd be like look mom
I'm inside again that might be more
normal than what I did yeah yeah a
little bit there's a little bit
[Music]